Грузія зараз прокидається і це
надзвичайно важливо тому що
ми бачимо
нинішній грузинський уряд є
м'яко кажучи не Дружня до України так
можливо це є наслідком того що
в Україні
дали притулок громадянство
Саакашвілі який як для
грузинського уряду ворогом але це не
привід
робити
Такі речі як зробили грузини а
найгірше Що вони зробили та по
грузинський уряд Я маю на увазі це
найгірше це
дали можливість
російським
фірмам закуповувати товари під санкційні
через грузинські фірми прокладки
експортувати їх уже з Грузії на
територію Росії мало того у 2008 році
Україна тоді президент Ющенко а допоміг
Грузії надавши
е-е грузинам зброєю і зокрема частини
протиповітряної оборони і я сам пам'ятаю
я був
автором першої постанови щодо визнання
росія-агресором у Верховній Раді України
Тоді за неї не проголосували
[музика]
голосувала лише фракції нашої країни
народного самооборона батьківщина тоді
і інші фракції відмовилися голосувати за
це ясна річ що Партія регіонів теж А я
тоді з трибуни Верховної Ради називав
Путіна фашистом і
сказав слова
тобто Слава Грузії
Мені дуже прикро А що сьогодні
грузинський уряд робить дії на Шкоду
Україні і те що грузини повстали через
те що грузинське парламент зараз
намагався зробити те що шкодить самій
Грузії для її європейського майбутнього
це ми не дуже
сильно надихає і я вірю що який був Уряд
не був
мені чесно кажучи я не буду не можу
влазити у внутрішні справи суверенної
держави але я дуже хочу вірити що
грузинський Народ не дасть жодному
своєму уряду зупинити шлях європейської
і євроатлантичної інтеграції і Україна
Грузія і Молдова разом будуть підступати
до європейських євроатлантичних структур
бо це справедливо бо це результат
нашої спільної всіх трьох країн
багаторічної 10 багато 10-річної
зараз це дійсно тест великий для
грузинського суспільства наскільки воно
зможе захистити європейські цінності